après 47 ans d'alliance le divorce entre
le royaume uni chez l'union européenne a
été acté le 31 janvier 2020 les deux
parties se sont donnés une période de
transition qui court jusqu'à la fin de
l'année
objectif partir en bons termes et éviter
le no deal mais le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est que c'est plus facile à dire
qu'à faire
malgré le dernier tête à tête en
visioconférence entre boris johnson et
ursula von der leyen
les négociations sont au point mort
des progrès ont été réalisés ces
dernières semaines mais les divergences
significatives persiste non seulement
dans le domaine de la pêche mais aussi
en termes de réglementation ou de
gouvernance
ils ont donné pour instruction à leurs
chefs négociateurs de travailler
intensément de manière à essayer de
combler les divergences des scissions 31
décembre londres et bruxelles
maintiendront des liens étroits
garantissant notamment le principe de
libre circulation des biens et des
personnes
faute d'accord à cette date un retour
aux règles de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce avec droits de douane à la clé
constituerait une rupture susceptible
d'ébranler un peu plus d économie déjà
fragilisée par l'épidémie de kobe 19 les
prochains jours seront décisifs tant que
les négociations se poursuivent
je suis optimiste optimiste le premier
ministre britannique l'est tout autant
mais il se montre plus ferme avec ou
sans accord le royaume uni se portera
très bien dit il
je ne veux pas particulièrement qu'on
aboutisse à une relation comme celle
avec l'australie ou basé sur les règles
de l'om sait mais nous pouvons très bien
vivre avec ça je pense que nous pouvons
puissamment prospérer dans ces
circonstances
l'union européenne doit comprendre que
nous sommes tout à fait sérieux sur la
nécessité de contrôler nos propres lois
et de propre réglementation sauf que le
temps presse le 31 décembre approche et
la présidente de la commission
européenne en a bien conscience
nous devrions intensifier les
négociations cela vaut la peine d'y
travailler dur nous manquons de temps un
éventuel accord menacé par les dernières
tensions apparues entre londres et
bruxelles
en cause le projet de loi britannique
qui revient sur certains engagements
pris dans le traité encadrant le brésil
it
le texte revient notamment sur des
dispositions pour la province
britannique d'irlande du nord prévu pour
éviter le rétablissement d'une frontière
un retour en arrière pas vraiment du
goût de bruxelles qui a riposté par le
lancement d'une procédure d'infraction
contre le royaume uni et qui peut finir
devant la cour de justice de l'union
européenne
autant dire que rien ne va plus et que
le pire est peut-être à venir